your sense of who you are is derived
from
thought live you say in the present
live only in the present
but i don't want the present i want
reality
the more you let go of your stuff
the more you are yourself what is
meditation
you meditate some of you don't you now
may i hold
where's i
beside this body and mind and voice
there's i
so if we investigate you can't find
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
you can develop awareness in your life
enjoy
most of the the self-talk the voice in
the head is conditioned by one's past
it's conditioned by one's education
one's upbringing the culture you've been
brought up in
and many personal factors your parents
and so on
all these makes up the kind of talk that
happens in your head a great step
forward
is already to realize that there is a
voice in your head that talks all the
time
because that's that really i would say
that it's the first glimpse of an
awakening because to realize that there
is a
a continuous self-talk happening a lot
of it
totally unnecessary by the way it's
happening we're not talking about the
thinking that is helpful and useful and
can solve problems in your life and
create new things
the mind is potentially a wonderful tool
to be able to
use in that way but for many people the
mind is a kind of torture instrument
80 percent of their lives and they would
be
much happier and much more productive
without the self-talk so the first
realization is that there is a voice
and that i call it the first awakening
because
you that means something else has come
in a we could call that
another dimension of consciousness has
come in which we could call
awareness i sometimes call it awareness
we could call it presence
and i think in buddhist terminology that
would be called
mindfulness i personally don't use the
term although i it's a wonderful thing
mindfulness i don't use the term because
implies that your mind is full
but but it's actually realizing they're
they're at that and this is the
beginning of reeling there are two there
are
two dimensions of consciousness possible
in you
one is the dimension of thinking which
is great
but a more a more vital and deeper
dimension
is a dimension of simple awareness
where this which means consciousness
when you think
consciousness takes on a particular form
every thought
is a thought form it's an energy
formation
not a scientist you're a scientist but i
think
if if you're totally honest as a
scientist
you will probably admit don't ask for
too much no
you will probably admit that science
even now doesn't quite know what
a thought is my approach is not
scientific but i think there's a lot to
be said for looking at it from a
scientific
angle but my approach is totally
experiential so you can see for yourself
find yourself there is that voice and
then you become aware that
that voice has certain patterns to it
repetitive thought patterns that tend to
occur again and again perhaps every day
of your life
i had thoughts for years i had certain
thoughts like
uh whenever something happened that
wasn't good
i had a thought that would comment on it
in my mind and it would say
of course bad things always happen to me
it's bound to happen to me it's of
course
always bad things happen to me and they
did
so it always confirmed that i was right
and and
then with the disidentification realists
there is a space of you from where you
can beware what kind of thoughts are
going through your mind all the time
and that the awareness of thought is not
a thought
it's simply the ability to look at a
thought like a light shining on a
thought
and i call that pure or unconditioned
consciousness whereas the thought is
consciousness that has become a form
an analogy we could use is to say that
consciousness is the vast ocean and
thinking
is the waves and ripples on the surface
of the ocean
and every wave and ripple has a very
short-lived life it's very fleeting like
every thought
but it pretends to have an independent
existence
and and then what happens is this
continuous identification with the
stream of thinking
leads to a very serious
dysfunction in one's sense of identity
because then your sense of who you are
your sense of
highness is derived your sense of self
is derived from whatever your mind is
telling you about yourself
i ideas opinions viewpoints about
yourself
in other words your sense of who you are
is derived from thought and that
was recognized already by the ancient
teachers like the buddha
as erroneous an illusion there is
it is in all the ancient teachings
expressed in different words
there is a deeper sense of self possible
to humans
that is not thought where you are when
you drew the
sense yourself but not as a story in the
head
so you no longer derive your identity
from something you are telling yourself
in your head
which is extremely limiting and we call
that in spiritual terms
ego it's not quite the same way in which
freud uses ego so this is the
in when we use it spiritually use the
word ego basically means
complete identification with a stream of
thinking
and complete absence of awareness so you
are
con you are then it's not only the
thinking of course then what you say
and what you do your actions are totally
controlled by the conditioned mind
conditioned by the past
reactive patterns so this is how many
people
they relive or live out their parents
unconsciousness how the the faulty
upbringing the dysfunctional upbringing
for their parents they then inflict it
on their children
it often goes back many many generations
similar dysfunctional patterns
so you inherit the conditioning is
inherited
it occupies your mind until somebody
comes
and says you told me before we met this
happened to you you had a very
dysfunctional upbringing
and then it can happen the bug stops
here and your
awareness suddenly comes in and you are
no longer
forced to re-enact the old conditioning
of your mind
one of the things that first comes to
mind you know if we were
just to try to say in a few words
what's mindfulness a very common
response might be
well it's living in the present moment
it's being in the present
so that's a pretty good beginning
because as
probably all of you know and especially
since
almost everybody here has a meditation
practice
you're all very aware of
how much of the time we are lost in
thoughts of past and lost
in thoughts of future sometimes
very very little time is actually spent
in the moment you know because of this
proliferation
of thoughts so the first response what
is mine
well it's living in the moment not being
so lost and pissed not being so lost in
the future
but this is actually not quite enough
mindfulness means something more than
just living in the moment
there's an example of this
and i'm just using this particular
example because i happen to
love this particular breed of dogs
are you familiar with black labs
something it could be any it could be
any
animal but i i like yeah they're playful
and they're happy and they're
always happy to see you and they're kind
of running around
they are living in the present they're
not lost in the past they're not lost in
the future they
are right there in the present moment
but based on my astute observation of
them
they don't look all that mindful
you know they're just kind of being led
around mostly by their nose
you know and having a grand old time
very much
in the present but not
really mindful so mindfulness has to
mean
something more than just being in the
present
or else we would all be practicing what
i call
black lab consciousness right
and so we're not doing that or hopefully
we're not doing that
there's a portuguese poet
named fernando pessoa
and i just happened to come across a
book of his poetry and there was one
poem
which grabbed my attention the title
was very interesting to me
the title of it of the poem was is
live you say in the present
okay in the first few lines of the poem
live you say in the present
live only in the present
but i don't want the present i want
reality
so i thought that's an interesting take
and take on things
how do we come to the reality how do we
come to a deeper reality
than simply living in the present so
we're not
confined by this black lab
consciousness there has to be something
more something bigger
a further dimension to mindfulness
so then we might say well it it is
living in the present but
what we need in addition is a certain
observing power of the mind
so that as we know what's happening we
know that we're knowing right and this
is something that black labs don't
particularly seem to have
okay so maybe mindfulness is this
observing power of the mind
we're getting closer here you know in
our meditation
we'll often speak up yes observe what's
happening
right observe the thoughts observe the
breath
another way of understanding what this
observing power of the mind is
as opposed to simply being present
is an experience we all have very many
times and i'm sure you had
just in a few minutes of meditation we
did
it's seeing it's experiencing the
difference
between being lost in a thought
and being aware that we're thinking
so are you familiar with that difference
it happens a lot
right we're very often thoughts are
happening
and if we're not aware if we're not
mindful we're carried along
on the train of association so we're in
the thought we're in that whole thought
process and one
could even say we're present
in the thought process but we don't
know that we're thinking so the
observing power of mind
gives us that extra perspective
you know as thoughts are there or images
or
emotions or mind states the observing
power of
mind knows that we're knowing them
this opens up the possibility then of
huge arenas of investigation
through this observing power of the mind
we can really start
investigating different aspects
of the reality that pessoa was talking
about
i don't want the present i want reality
but this observing power of the mind
is still not yet mindfulness
you know so this exploration keeps
getting deeper
we need to be living in the present but
it's more than living in the present
we need to be cultivating the observing
power of the mind
in order to investigate
all of the aspects of our experience
but mindfulness is more than just the
observing power
because we can be observing experience
and we often are through
many different filters in the mind
we can be observing experience through
the
filter of desire
we can be observing things through the
filter
of anger or aversion or through the
filter of
delusion you know there's just a
cloudiness we're observing we're in that
mode
but the observation is being
conditioned by the particular mind state
so just a few simple examples of this
you know when we're observing things
through the filter of desire or wanting
there's something i call catalog
consciousness
have you ever made the mistake
of opening a catalogue
and then turning pages
waiting for something to want
it's remarkable
no nothing on this page maybe i'll want
something on the next page
and it's a rare person who can put the
catalog
down before the last page
because maybe there'll be something i
want
so that whole time we may be observing
what we're seeing but it's all through
the
filter of wanting that's not mindfulness
so mindfulness has to be mean more than
simply observing
another example this happened
when i was practicing at a monastery in
burma
and i was had been there for quite a
while
you know in intensive meditation and
the whole body just felt open and a free
flow of energy and light and
felt pretty good but there was one
knot in the neck you know like that
and i was observing it and being with it
and i went to my teacher said
and i was reporting my experience and i
said you know
everything is really open and there's a
lot of light tingling pleasant
sensations but there's this one energy
block
in the neck and i thought
that i was describing the experience
objectively right everything's open but
there's this block
he pointed out that the very
word the very concept block
contained within it desire and aversion
just by naming it or holding it as a
block
it implied i don't want this
i want it to open aversion to what's
present
wanting something else
and in all that time i thought i was
being mindful of it
because i was observing it and i hadn't
noticed that i was
observing it through this filter
of aversion to what was there and
wanting something else
so you're beginning to see kind of the
nuances of mindfulness
mindfulness means the observing
power of the mind so that has to be
there
but the mind that is free
of desire and aversion and delusion
mindfulness means we're seeing we're
with experience
free of those filters
and so it takes quite a lot of
practice and attention
to really check to see okay what is the
attitude in the mind
with respect to the present experience
and this is a very useful
meditation technique so in in whatever
way you're practicing
periodically and it can be reasonably
frequently
it can be very helpful to ask the
question
with whatever the present experience is
well what's the
attitude in the mind now about this
uh destructive emotion very much based
on
appearances you convince
things exist as appears and
some nice thing attachment some negative
thing
anger so now some student
now they uh express so once
they believe nothing exists as appears
that automatically reduce the grasping
something independent existence there
that's the basis of
and all this negative emotion
so therefore they quantum physics
uh not only external thing
but observer also you see
through centuries investigation
where is i uh
that's observer so no
there's no independent eye
now may i hold where is i
beside this body and mind and voice
there's i
so if we investigate we can't find
recently i met uh among the
audience one old lady
she she's seeking some kind of blessing
from me
because her mind so too much
anxiety i asked her
where is self where is i where is you
she responds here
i hear then i ask
round or square she
answered round
so you know investigate where is
i we cannot
sort of find the rear or basis of
i so the
anatma theory is essentially
ultimately we cannot find even if
the controversies this as
like external thing observer himself or
herself
investigate beside this body mind
a voice nothing
we can pinpoint
you have the power as consciousness to
do these things and to research yourself
you leave everything aside everything
that you call yours and
leave everything aside and still there's
something here that nobody can put from
here to there
only this is left this you can try and
take it now you cannot take it down
anything else you can take out whatever
you can take out belongs to time
time says anyway that belongs to me
what they cannot take out does not
belong to time
so we have come to this place everything
you can put aside
belongs to time but this what's left
doesn't belong to time
and every day we feed into
we make certain kind of affirmations you
can call them the word affirmation i
mean that
you are affirming over and over yes i am
this person
every day you leave your home you go out
into public space
with this notion of yourself i'm a
person and if you believe i am a person
then everybody else is a person and also
you're telling the world this is how you
treat me as a person
because that's how i'm looking at you as
a person
so we all play this game very well
so when someone look at you they see a
person
they don't see god they don't see
harmony
they say person because
that's what you take yourself to be if
you take yourself to be
just your person why should anyone else
take you to be a different
because your self-belief is the most
important thing
what you believe gives you your life
so when you're empty and not miserably
empty
when you're empty i wonder what people
will
pick up from you please let's look at it
if you are empty because every day we go
out in life
we are carrying something
your last problem or what you want for
the day your desire or
i don't want to meet the world today
some people have big headphones
when they go out or a helmet i mean i
don't want to engage with
anybody you're wearing a helmet you
don't even have a bike
i don't want to know i don't want any
business with anybody
so that is your message that's what you
have to offer today
i'm not in contact i don't like any of
you
keep out of my way or
i'm nice please love me i need it
i need to be accepted or whatever thing
what will people see if you are empty
will they go oh he's something
is that that one what will what they
will perceive
oh i've seen that guy we're so empty
but don't go around thinking you're
empty it doesn't work actually
i'm really empty i'm very empty
this guy is strange
don't think you have to be empty beyond
the concept or the intention to be empty
like now something just let go
and you find it the more you let go of
you the more you there is
what a paradox the more you let go
of your stuff the more you are
yourself what is
meditation
would you kindly tell me what is
meditation
you meditate some of you don't you
no oh god
what some of you do
don't you what is meditation
the word is a common language in the
dictionary
it means to ponder over
to think over and
to concentrate learn to
concentrate on something not let your
brain
wander all over the place right
right is that what you call meditation
be simple sorry be honest
that is what giving every day
certain period of and you go
to your room quietly sit down for 10
minutes of now
meditate right right
do you agree with that sir no
then what is meditation to you
concentration
thinking about something very noble
[Music]
you can't announce questions
so we are going to first encourage what
is meditation
any conscious effort to meditate
instead is part of your discipline
of the office
because you said that if i'm meditating
i'll have a
quiet mind or i'll enter into another
state
and so so the word meditation also
means to measure
to measure which means compare
so your meditation becomes mechanical
right because you are exercising
energy to concentrate on
a picture image or an idea and
that concentration divides
right
concentration is always given
no i want to concentrate on that
but thought wonders so then i say
i mustn't wander off come back you
repeat that all day long
or half an hour and then you come off
it and say well i've meditated
and this meditation is advocated by all
the gurus by all the
you know they disciples
things in the world meditation
which is measurement as you have seen
which is comparison of achievement
that's not meditation and
don't accept anything the speaker says
at any price
this speaker says that's not meditation
at all
that's merely a process of achievement
right you are being one day not able to
concentrate
you take a month and say yes i've got it
that's like a talk becoming a manager
right so is there a different
kind of meditation
which is not effort
which is not measurement which is not
routine
please pay attention to what i'm saying
which is not mechanical
is there a meditation in which there is
no sense of comparison
or there is no reward and punishment
so is there any meditation which is
not based on thought which is
measurement time and all that
you understand the question
how can one explain
a meditation that has no measurement
that has no achievement that doesn't say
i am
i will be that
i am this but i become that
that being god or super angel
so that requires
if i may point out not for you to accept
or deny just
pointing out
is there a meditation which has nothing
to do with
will with our
energy that must meditate
which has nothing to do with effort at
all
the speaker
says there is you don't have to accept
it
he may be nuts
[Music]
he may be talking nonsense
but he sees the logically
the ordinary meditation is self-hypnosis
deceiving oneself
and when you stop deceiving stop
all that mechanical process is there a
different kind of meditation
and unfortunately the speaker says
yes that's not for you
say yes i'll agree i'll meditate
[Music]
you can't get at it through effort
through giving all your energy to
something you can't there is no
understanding it is something that has
to be
absolutely silent
don't achieve science now don't sit in
[Music]
meditation
please don't do itself
[Music]
you can't do it first of all begin very
humbly
very very humble and therefore very
gently
and therefore no pushing driving
there must be it requires tremendous
sense of not only a loneliness
but it's sensible i mustn't describe it
i mustn't describe it
because then you will go off on
descriptions
if i describe it the description is not
the real
right the description
of the moon all of the himalayas
painted description is not the himalayas
right so
we'll stop describing it it's for you
to play with it or not play it
go your own way and your own peculiar
achievements through your meditation of
sorts rewarding all the rest of it
so a meditation
which is absolutely
no effect
no achievement no thinking
then the brain is quiet
you understand not made quiet by
will by intention by conclusion
and all that nonsense it is quiet
and being quiet it has
infinite space
so is your brain
ever quiet
i'm asking your brain thinking
fearing and
your office work
[Music]
you think about your family what they
will do when
your sons your doctors think
which is time and
thought is your brain ever quiet
[Music]
is your brain up acquired not made quiet
by drugs and by all kinds of inducements
risky or various forms of
[Music]
drugging yourself
you are drugging yourself all the time
therefore you have no
energy
of that kind that demands
into the penetration of something
emits
so we're going now back to find out
what is creation
you're asking what is creation
because which has nothing to do with
invention that's god
so what is the creation the origin the
beginning what is life
tell me says what you think of it tell
me
what is life not going to the office and
all the rest of the sex and children or
no children but
sex and sciences
what is life
what gives life to that blade of grass
in this cement innocence
what is life in us not only
things that we go through power position
prestige fame or
no feeling but say
so that's not life that's not
that's part of our mishandling of
love but it is
life you will tell me a question
is there a brain your brain
which is not murder
muddied
by environment by tradition by society
and others
so what is the origin
of life
awaiting me to answer it
[Music]
you are waiting for the speaker to
answer that question
oh you would can you tell me yes or no
i'll wait
and if you tell me
then i'll go
this much to a serious subject for you
to play with
because we are trying to enter any car
into something that has no
name no
and i can kill that word
there is another bird i can't tell
all birds there are too many of them in
the world
so we are inquiring to what
makes a world what's the
what is creation behind all these
the origin is nameless
the origin is absolutely quiet
it's not worrying about making noise
creation is something
that's most holy
that's the most sacred thing in life
and if you have made a mess of your life
changed
change it today not tomorrow
if you are uncertain
[Music]
find out why and be certain
if your thinking is not straight
think straight logically
unless all that is prepared all that is
settled you can't entry to this world
into the world of creation if you want
to see the top 10 rules i did on the
dalai lama check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and i'll
see you there
if you do wrong things mainly
harming other you get negative
consequences
some say something good person some say
bad person that doesn't matter